[Music]
many people have discovered that the
Internet is a great place to build up a
large social media following and desired
career as an online celebrity
although these internet stars are
good-looking in their own right
we can't help but notice that some of
them have a striking resemblance to our
favorite celebs if you're new to our
channel don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and please give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we're sharing photos of 10 internet
sensations who look exactly like famous
people Jimmy rose English lingerie model
Jimmy Rose became internet famous when
she dated Tyga during his brief breakup
from Kylie Jenner when Tyga stepped out
with Jimmy people put in help but notice
the model looked exactly like Selena
Gomez they both have the same adorable
faces the same tiny stature and the same
beautiful brown hair these two are
definitely long-lost sisters don't you
think Claudia island Megan Fox is
drop-dead gorgeous with stunning
features in a flawless physique to go
right along with it and her internet
look-alike is just as beautiful as she
is her name's Claudia Allen and she's
known as the Brazilian Megan Fox after
taking one look at the photos on this
beauty queens Instagram account it's no
surprise that she has over 8 million
followers which is 5 million more than
what Megan has I guess being a celebrity
look like it's definitely paying off for
Claudia April Gloria a cosplayer from
Kansas named April Gloria look so much
like Taylor Swift and the resemblance is
shocking April doesn't have to try hard
to copy Taylor's appearance and facial
expressions
she just naturally looks exactly like
the senior right down to her short on
hair nose lips and I we can only imagine
how many times April gets stopped while
out in public by people who mistake her
for the pop star Conrad and I read
Swedish model and Instagram celebs
Conrad Anna run hit the genetic lottery
because he looks exactly like Hollywood
heartthrob Leonardo DiCaprio Conrad says
people call him Leo everywhere he goes
and they even ask to take pictures with
him he says the attention is a fixed
hiring but we definitely think we should
embrace his celebrity doppelganger and
go into business as a Leo impersonators
Chelsea ma Chelsea Mar made the Internet
absolutely wild due to her and candy
resemblance to Angelina Jolie Chelsea
admits she has had Mozilla's breast
implants and a nose job but she denies
getting the procedures so that she can
look more like Maleficent actress
although Chelsea doesn't see the
resemblance between herself and Angelina
over 100,000 of her Instagram followers
probably disagree
Jackie Vasquez Jackie Vasquez has
figured out that looking like ariana
grande is her claim to the internet fame
and it doesn't take much for her to look
like the side-to-side singer whether her
hair is in a high ponytail or in
voluminous curls Jackie looks exactly
like a singers long-lost sister she's
definitely loving the attention from her
hundreds of thousands of Instagram
followers to clutter accounts with
comments such as oMG he looks just like
Ari kelsey combine with over 1 million
Instagram followers and Counting kelsey
calamine is enjoying her online success
thanks to her resemblance of kylie
jenner from their hair to their eyes and
full pouty lips Kylie and Kelsey look
exactly like there was definitely
separated at birth we would love to see
Kelsey snag a guest role on Keeping Up
with a Kardashian wouldn't it be cool to
see her standing side by side next to
her celebrity twins it would blow our
mind
Camilla Osmond many people try to copy
Kim Kardashian's look but it takes a lot
more than a skin-tight dress from
highlight and contour to look like the
reality TV Queen Kim has a very unique
look and we never thought we see someone
who looks exactly like her Camilla
Osmond gained internet notoriety when
people discovered she was Kim's twin
Camilla even made an appearance on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians and it
was almost as if we were looking at
identical twins it's definitely hard to
tell these two apart
Taylor schemes YouTube star Taylor
schemes has a huge social media
following because she's super talented
and pretty darn awesome
Taylor is beautiful in her own right but
don't you think she looks a lot like
Disney star dove Cameron they have the
same blonde hair the same big eyes and
even matching button noses if does ever
needs a body double on living daddies
she could definitely give Taylor a call
cameron dallas internet personality
cameron dallas
able to transition his career from vine
and YouTube into a bona fide star and
the Netflix reality show chasing Cameron
with his good looks and charming
personality
it's no wonder Cameron gets a lot of
attention from the lady and it also
helps that he looks a lot like Justin
Bieber it seems like we're not the only
ones who see the resemblance between the
two of them after Sophia Richie's
relationship with Justin ended she moved
on to Cameron and we wouldn't be
surprised if she was attracted to
Cameron simply because she looks a lot
like the beam which of these celebrity
look-alikes shocked you the most react
in the comments section down below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
[Music]